iter elle est indiscutable
le respect des gestes barrières
sont tout à fait capables de faire les
lieux culturels les salles de spectacle
les cinémas les lieux de concerts est
pas le stade de france mais en tout cas
les lieux transfère x est absolument un
scandale parce que moi je viens du métro
pour noranda mon centre de vaccination
la fréquence des métros a été diminuée
il y avait la foule dans métro et ça
tout le monde s'en fout parce que les
les jeunes doivent aller au boulot vous
comprenez que ça n'intéresse personne
que tu d'accord pour la réouverture des
lieux culturels avec une distance et un
masque pour protéger les champs bâton
peut pas vivre sans culture et sans
preneur moi je m'appelle pour de
landreau humoriste classieux j'avais
écrit un spectacle que je contacte terre
est actuellement on peut plus rien faire
parce qu'on outils dans trois semaines
ça ira mieux
moi je crois pas que faire mieux peuvent
que macro et trop têtu pas les
conditions jugées plus il va falloir
rester gestes-barrières paraître
on fait jusqu'à maintenant mais qu'un
nombre limité d'entrer dans les musées
mais je pense que c'est nécessaire mais
oui il y en a marre donc ce serait bien
même en respectant les gens c'est le
geste et maria complète
bizjak vous assistez à condition
évidemment du port du masque
distanciation sociale
mais là ce n'est pas par exemple c'est
qu'en ce moment
transports en commun talons surpris
version coupé à son plein et on
pouvait pas
c'est moins à l'intérieur des murs parce
que là on peut faire une jauge
un endroit où qui peut accueillir 300
personnes ont peu on pourrait en
accueillir 80 par exemple je dis ça
maintenant c'est au moment où les gens
rentrent et sortent c'est là le problème
parce que les gens vont être côte à côte
je vois par exemple le stade qui est à
côté qui le parc des princes un stade de
60000 personnes vous pouvez tout à fait
poursuit derek 20000 personnes sais rien
surtout s'est disséminé mais vous avez
déjà vu l'entrée du parc
comme ça bouchonne parce qu'il ya les
mesures de sécurité qu'il faut faire il
faut fouiller les gens et ses errements
de la sortie c'est pareil certes ce
niveau là que ça pose problème des
siècles niveau là qu'il faut trouver des
solutions
suite à ces sabots râble après pour les
allez cinéma le port du masque ne mange
pas les théâtres aussi port du masque à
puis ça devrait pas poser trop trop de
souci par rapport à ça pareil pour les
musées vous y a pas plus de monde dans
un vivier 6 et régulé que dans une
grande surface a eu un mot garde le mas
bien entendu et des gestes barré tout ça
moi je suis pour ces lieux où on peut
maintenir les astres barrière c'est
important et ça du coup
je pense que c'est possible de le faire
après pour tout ce qui est plus festif
et avec de la nourriture on enlève son
masque etc
je pense que c'est plus compliqué
peut-être mais il ya des lieux qui
pourraient certainement d ouvrir moi je
suis favorable effectivement la
réouverture des conditions comme on fait
partout dans les grandes surfaces au
travail
partout ou quasiment respecté les gestes
barrière
tout simplement je pense que
c'est pas non plus sorcier 1
moi je pense qu'il faut
vous ai déjà bain pour les gens qui
aiment la culture française et tout ça
mais je pense qu'effectivement dans
certains
quartier où il n'y a pas vraiment
s'il n'y a pas tout ça
effectivement est ce qu on
aussi certaines bibliothèques puisqu'il
était aussi sont fermés et je pense
qu'il faudra aussi dans certains
quartiers devait réouvrir les
bibliothèques et réouvrir par rapport à
certains jeunes qu'ils ont des activités
ou aujourd'hui sont priés peuvent rien
faire je pense aussi que l'un ne va pas
sans l'autre